Leonidas is the king and he has his
Queen
when when someone comes to his doorstep
and threatens him literally threatens
his his whole livelihood of his people
with literally cutting people's heads
off walking up to him and showing
violence
his Queen stepped up and said
this is not okay
and the messenger was turning around and
saying how dare you as a woman speak
and in the end when Leonidas then before
he kicked them down the well
he actually said you disrespected my
queen and actually what she said as well
is she said like only Spartan women can
give birth to Spartan men which is
strong men so what is beautiful about
that relationship is that they are not
equal in the sense that they don't have
the same energy but
we can agree that they're both strong in
different ways that's not a partnership
because he needs okay so what I meant is
I'm not saying they're eating she needs
him more than he needs her so what I'm
saying is I'm not saying that they're
equal and that they give the same thing
in but what they do is that they
complement each other and support each
other and the beautiful thing about that
relationship is that she's actually very
accomplished so he feels safe walking
away and going into war potentially
never coming back but he knows that his
wife is strong so she can go and she
will use her way of doing things to try
and help the country can I just say
something so is it is a definition of a
partnership 50 50 right you're right so
I think that's the biggest problem
for men when we hear partnership because
we think
when we hear 50 50 we think hold on so
if we gotta if we gotta get into a fight
now it's not 50 50 because if someone
comes to robust down the street right
now it's not 50 50. I've got to deal
with 100 of the I gotta deal with him so
when we hear partnership we think that's
cool because there's certain places
where we want women to be feminine so if
we're a family gathering you might be
more vocal than us that's fine because
we don't want to talk so there's it's
like a partnership doesn't have to be 50
50 in my opinion we can you can have a
solid relationship without having to be
50 50 all the way we can you can be
bearish women can be better some things
and men as I you're more maternal than
us you can do with children better than
us we're fine with that the problem with
women nowadays in my opinion we're
trying to make everything so equal and
it's like it's just not like that it's
not enough it's not it's not in our
biological it's not innate at all yeah
and I agree with you with that as well
because I I I guess I have the my
definition of Partnerships a bit
different from you so when I'm seeing a
partnership I didn't mean it has to be
100 50 50 in every single aspect right
but you're changing the definition of a
word okay
so I do apologize I'm not trying no I'm
not offended I'm just I'm just saying
like that's not what it means um
question for you what have you seen in
divorce court do you feel like men and
women demonize each other the same
what's your experience with that uh
no I think women are more ready to just
demonize their husband like if they're
going in the arena of divorce like okay
this is happening they're ready to just
cut him out as much you know whatever
way possible
and I've seen very confident lovers like
okay what's going on who is this you
know where does this come from and then
he just has to it's sad so first initial
reaction he's he's sad he's like okay
this is this is where it's going and
then he has to just now defend himself
all his accusations so yeah and then he
might be disgusted and then he's just
retaliating but she's the one that
always starts it glad you said I've seen
just saying how it is so I'm curious um
have you had I know the majority of
divorces are initiated by women have you
had men initiate divorce yeah sometimes
what are the typical reasons that men
initiate from what you've seen so what
I've seen so sometimes it's adultery
okay or she gets to like she's trying to
take charge in the house and started
demanding things so she's she doesn't
have to like if she's if especially if
she's educated so she's got a job
and she's coming home late and then she
can't she's too tired too what's the
percentage is just roughly off your
experience of men initiating divorcement
initiated divorce the percentage well I
don't know because I know I know the
percentage that Paul's got statistics
but what have you seen in your own
experience that men initiate yeah like
roughly the last time we saw is around
like 15
really and yeah that means it's a cystic
spot on me that's how bad it is yeah but
again the English quotes I have to say
we it's not like straight away it's not
as bad as California I'm going to say
for for example how how long do you
think women want to leave marriages
before they do
about how long yeah typically so from as
soon as they get married and yeah like
like um they just always say like if a
girl starts working out and going to the
gym she's leaving your ass
I mean that's really relative I don't
know maybe I would say it's like six
months six months to a few years it
sounds really extreme but if it keeps
happening there's all these pattern
suits yeah okay
um so what about you guys do you guys
have ex-girlfriends no I never never had
an ex really yeah no I got a girl no
I've never had it how are you doing well
we was together 10 years and we split
off for three years and then we got back
together okay yeah oh that's pretty cute
yeah
um does she demonize you oh yeah 100 she
does yeah
um
I'm not going to get into the details
because I'm not here to be emotional or
anything like that but it was um it was
quite uh let's just say abusive simply
um and she loved to demonize me for it
and you know I had the the mindset back
then I still do you know like if she's
dressing as we'd say like a slug then I
won't have it and I said to her like if
you want to dress like that that's fine
but don't like don't be with me you know
you still got your choice I'm not
controlling choice but she'd take that
admit me into being controlling but
like I don't know she turned me into the
the demon and then um
I think what she's doing is girth
lighting so which sadly happens both
ways because I personally have only have
one ex and he did exactly that to me for
a good two years and it's it's it it's
it's been literally a life-changing
experience and I think what's really sad
is that this is literally like it
doesn't matter what gender there are
good people out there who just you know
we were simple-minded people who just
wanted to we were excited to meet
someone who we thought we were going to
be happy with and these people are
they're so good at manipulating you they
love bomb you they say you oh my God I
love you I want to have your kids what
like you just fall for them and when
they have their clothes in you boom
right they start coming in and you're
like I think girls like toxic man I
agree I agree yeah yeah I think like
there's something you're attracted to
about it do you know why
um well I think it's because like the
same traits the hero has the villain has
too so if a dude is very like they
always say like why does that girl stay
with her girlfriend or that why does the
girl stay with the boyfriend that beats
her up well it's because like that
aggression that's in the hero is also in
the villain you're gonna go if when they
say like they got a crush a celebrity
crush or something I guarantee he's
gonna be in a villain in the movie if
they let the bad guys it's just
would it be okay if I just just make the
distinction and the reason why these
girls are getting it wrong
yes they women actually go look in a
romance novel men like their corn girls
like the books we look very differently
and you can go to Romans now one in a
bookstore you can see that girls tend to
go for the hunky guys the the vampires
the bad boys and they changed them right
it's all about changing them now now now